GABRIELA FERRARA: Hello.
In this video, we are
going to do an introduction
on how Google optimizes
storage on persistent disks
to increase database performance
and why we can disable safely
the double write
feature in MySQL
even though everybody
recommends not doing it.
Having that in mind, we
are proud to announce
that in the past 12 months,
the performance of Cloud
SQL for MySQL and
[INAUDIBLE] has doubled.
According to the
benchmarks, when
moving from 128 to 256
threads, show the performance
a change of 1,502 tps
through 3,002 tps.
Not bad.
It's not enough to
show performance.
More importantly, it's to
show consistent performance.
One of the keys to get
this type of performance
for your own deployments
realizes setting some custom
flags or system variables.
For instance, I know
the B log file size.
I know the BIO capacity
and max allowed packet.
To understand what each of
those flags and system variables
does, I recommend you
to check out this URL.
The results are incredible.
All this scattered
performance points
seem to now converge
to a better alignment.
And when you have your
configuration set just right,
you get results like this where
scatter performance converges
to a more consistent alignment.
The main factors driving this
changing performance lining
disabling double writes
in the InnoDB engine.
| know what you're thinking.
Why are you doing
something that everybody
recommends you not to?
Why is Google taking
such a risk with my data?
The secret has to do
with understanding
how block sizes influences
performance at each layer.
On the first layer, we have
the persistent disk car
allowing 16 kilobytes as
physical block for writes.
On the second layer, we
have the ext4 file system
using a feature called
Big Lock that allows
for 16 kilobyte cluster sizes.
This is why the 16
kilobyte instance
allows us to disabled
double write safely.
The third layer involves
a container-optimized OS.
You may have heard
about it in Kubernetes.
And at last, we
have MySQL InnoDB
configured to have
double write off
and to use the old
direct as a flush method.
In a simplified way,
these four layers
are the key components of
the 16 kilobyte instance.
Our engineers work
in collaboration
with multiple teams
to make this happen.
If you want to know
more details as how
we did it with confidence,
watch the talk.
Oh, and by the way, you don't
have to take my word for it.
Our benchmarking code is open
sourced as PerfKitBenchmarker.
It can be found that
GitHub, and we'll
let you compare performance
for various products
across several call providers.
Check out the full talk for
more in the trenches details
and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more
great Next Rewind content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]